on this friday night multiplying
accusations russia is using banned
weapons
the fresh bombardments cities under
siege as food and supplies run out plus
why nato is rejecting ukraine's flee for
a no-fly zone europe's largest nuclear
power plant now in russian control
and criminalizing the news russia's
latest crackdown on independent media
crude awakenings it's ridiculous the
unprecedented rise in gas prices why the
war is only partly to blame
and steering ukrainian refugees to
safety they said you're our hero the
alberta man in the driver's seat
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
the head of nato says there is human
suffering and destruction on a scale not
seen in europe since the second world
war and he accused russia today of using
banned weapons
we have seen the use of
cluster bombs we have seen reports of
use of other
types of weapons would be which will be
in in violation of international law
cluster bombs detonate in midair
scattering munitions and killing
indiscriminately there were fresh pleas
from ukraine for nato to enforce a
no-fly zone over the country nato again
refused saying that would risk a
full-fledged war in europe well that
prompted an angry reaction from
ukraine's president
[Music]
everyone who dies from today will die
because of you said vladimir zelinski
because of your weakness he said
refusing the no-fly zone gives russia
the green light to keep bombing
at that nuclear power plant the fire is
now out but the russian military
is now in control of the plant the u.s
envoy to the u.n says the world narrowly
averted nuclear catastrophe
russian forces continue to make advances
the regions in red on this map show area
is now under russian control in the
south east and north the arrows show
territory still under ukrainian control
but where russian troops are advancing
including in areas close to the capital
kiev
our coverage begins tonight with redmond
shannon a high rise near kiev in flames
in the moments after it's hit by a shell
as russia's offensive across ukraine
intensifies and airstrikes hammer major
cities
rockets landing inside the capital too
bewildered citizens wondering where the
next one will drop
these are fired at houses all over
ukraine says this woman i hate these
people they are not even animals
across kiev ukrainians are resisting
digging in building roadblocks in
preparation for what's to come new
satellite images show the 60 kilometer
russian convoy it remains stalled
outside the city
the important black sea port of mario
paul is now surrounded by russian forces
its mayor says the city has no water or
power and food is running low thursday's
agreement between ukraine and russia on
humanitarian corridors could soon be
tested missiles keep dropping to the
on the civilians calls are constant for
a no-fly zone over the country this
counselor organizing supplies for
soldiers manny are her friends and i
decided to not fall down or
cry i decided to help to our
army ukrainian president vladimir
zelinski rallied supporters across
europe with a rousing speech friday
following reports he's survived three
assassination attempts in the past week
if ukraine falls all of europe will fall
he said
vladimir putin addressed neighboring
countries too urging leaders against new
sanctions perhaps a sign the measures
are working a third round of peace talks
between russia and ukraine is set for
this weekend but compromise seems
doubtful and peace is for now out of
reach donna
redman shannon in london thank you
well after heavy shelling overnight that
fire at europe's largest nuclear power
plant has been extinguished un and
ukrainian officials say no radiation was
released from the facility located north
of crimea but with this major plan now
under russian control and three others
within striking distance world leaders
are accusing russia of threatening the
safety of the entire continent ukraine's
president called it nuclear terrorism
with the potential to have caused much
wider damage including in neighboring
poland that's where our mike armstrong
is tonight
it was something locals had worried
about for days hoping to keep the
fighting away from the nuclear power
plant civilians had even set up
blockades it wasn't enough
russian troops attacked overnight in
what is being called a first in history
a full out fire fight over a nuclear
power plant surveillance video appears
to show bullets tracers and artillery
shells being fired there are also images
of a flare lighting up the area there
was a fire that started it was
extinguished
that fire was in a training building not
a part of the plant that produces power
this is our worst nightmare come true
this nuclear expert says the world may
have dodged a bullet
if the shell had hit in the wrong place
or a cooling system had been knocked
offline it could have been a disaster
i seriously doubt the russians are
targeting nuclear power plants that
would be crazy but accidents happen in
war all the time with six reactors the
plant is ukraine's biggest it's now
under the control of russian forces the
company that operates the facility says
its staff is still working but it is
having trouble communicating with them
we of course are fortunate according to
the international atomic agency none of
the reactors were affected and there was
no release of radioactive material the
operator and the regulator been telling
us that the situation is
naturally
continuous to be extremely tense
russian officials claim their soldiers
came under fire from the plant by what
they call ukrainian saboteurs
now the ukrainian president is appealing
to the russian people in this address he
urged them to remember the 1986
chernobyl disaster when the two nations
fought that catastrophe together
now even if this was just part of the
russian advance as it tries to take over
more territory and not an actual attack
on the plant it was reckless
most of the concern about a wider spread
in this conflict has been about nuclear
war but with four active major nuclear
power plants in ukraine a nuclear
accident is another thing to worry about
donna certainly is mike armstrong in
poland thank you canadian prime minister
justin trudeau today echoed nato's
position rejecting ukraine's multiple
requests for a no-fly zone over ukraine
the
thing that we have so far avoided and
will continue to need to avoid is
putting a situation in which nato forces
are in direct
conflict
with
russian soldiers that would be a level
of escalation that is unfortunate
that we need to avoid
the american secretary of state said
today russia has never been more
isolated the u.n security council held
an emergency meeting today the european
union said it wants to welcome ukraine
as a member as quickly as possible
jackson proskow reports
mr putin must stop this madness
and he must stop it now an emergency
meeting of the u.n security council
brought international condemnation of
russia's shelling and seizure of
europe's largest nuclear power plant
this is the first time that a state has
attacked
a fueled and functioning
nuclear power plant
moscow delivered only more defiance
another attempt
by the kiev authorities
to kindle artificial hysteria about what
is taking place in ukraine there's
little sense vladimir putin sees reason
to change course now
after nato foreign ministers agreed they
will not grant ukraine's wish to
establish a no-fly zone even as the
alliance predicts more bloodshed the
days to come
are likely to be worse
with more death
more suffering
and more destruction
the west seems to believe putin may find
his invasion unsustainable sanctions
have pushed russia's economy to the
brink of collapse russia's army has
suffered heavy losses and the kremlin is
now censoring news of the war at home
president putin
totally underestimated the strength of
the ukrainian armed forces
and they have been able to push back to
fight back and to slow down the russian
advances and in defiance of putin's
demands ukraine is quickly moving closer
to europe the eu said it wants ukraine
to become a member as soon as possible
while allies canada and the united
kingdom were invited to join a meeting
of european foreign ministers to shore
up support our goal
is to make sure that we put maximum
pressure on russia yet ukraine believes
it's not enough to deter putin's grand
ambitions warning nato may still have to
take up the fight it is so desperate to
avoid since the start of the invasion
there's been no formal contact between
the american military and the russian
military fearing this could spiral into
direct conflict the two sides have now
established a deconfliction hotline
donna the pentagon says it works they
say they placed a test call and the
russians answered
interesting jackson frasco in washington
thanks russia's neighbors are anxiously
watching this war play out latvia has
nato troops including canadians on the
ground conducting training missions as
mercedes stephenson reports from latvia
the future looks very uncertain
20 hours at a remote baltic border
crossing in the winter is a lot of time
to think and dmitry bikoff has had a lot
to think about as he waits in a long
line of trucks to cross the border into
his home country of russia hauling a
load of goods to moscow
bikov used to be in the russian military
he fears the war he thinks is wrong in
ukraine will see him back in uniform
drafted against his will
they can send me even there but why do i
need it it's scary scary very scary
bikoff says he wishes there was no
borders and he could fly free like a
bird and global leaders would get along
as well as the multinational truckers in
this line do
what's the difference russian or not
russian we are all people despite
dimitri's dream there are borders and
they're complicated here in latvia which
is flanked by both belarus and russia
we're here at the border between latvia
and belarus belarus is just behind me
you can see it back there past the
trucks that are lined up to go across
the border
the impact of the war being felt here
too
this bella russian truck driver says
he's worried for his family in ukraine
there are divides within latvia over the
war
24 percent of latvians are ethnic
russians many of them live in the region
of latkal
in dalgaf pills we found a clear
generational split over putin's actions
lana says she's an example of that part
of an older generation with fond
memories of russia she's glad crimea was
taken and says ukraine antagonized
moscow but she can't talk to her
daughter about it because it's causing a
rift her daughter is part of the younger
generation who dislikes putin
the latvian government is looking for
reassurance from nato and western
leaders to send a message to putin that
collective defense is still intact
that's a message that prime minister
justin trudeau will deliver himself next
week when he travels here to latvia
donna
filling up is getting more expensive
coming up what's fueling record high gas
prices it's not only the war
[Music]
if you've had to fill up your vehicle
lately you know the deal gas prices have
reached record highs in some places the
invasion of ukraine is part of the
reason but it's more complex than that
canada hasn't imported oil from russia
in years and crude prices are for oil
that will be delivered next month mike
trolley explains what's going on
it's fair to say canadians have never
seen a hike in gas prices quite like
this as i watch the gas go in the car i
see the dollar figure rising almost
twice as quickly as the leader figure
across the country records are breaking
a dollar 66 a liter in toronto and
halifax may be hard to swallow but look
at montreal at a dollar 79.9
or ottawa at a dollar 94.9
and then there's vancouver which is now
top two dollars a liter for the first
time ever outrageous like 75 bucks
doesn't even like give me
20 kilometers
the war in ukraine is the easy scapegoat
but it's far more complicated than that
any direct or indirect dealings in
russian sovereign debt earlier this week
canada shut its ports to russian cargo
ships a largely symbolic move since
canada hasn't imported much oil from
russia since 2019
a pair of tankers have already been
turned away they are carrying colombian
fuel to irving oil in new brunswick but
the ships themselves are russian owned
this ukraine russia situation has got
everybody just following the bouncing
barrels down the hill and the cost of
crude is going through the roof and the
speculation on where gasoline prices
will go and so far as the futures market
is concerned
is just out of control that uncertainty
is playing a big role in driving up
prices if sanctions are expanded to
include russian oil europe which imports
40 percent of its gas from russia will
have to bid against the rest of the
world including canada for available
supply this is not a thing where you
turn the switch off and on chocolate or
vanilla milkshake it's uh it's gonna
take a long time to get this back on
track to make matters worse what we're
seeing in oil prices today doesn't
impact the price at the pump until next
month so fill up now this is going to be
an expensive ride microlight global news
toronto
i had the risks for ukrainians fleeing
the country and those who have stayed
behind
there's a massive humanitarian push to
help the people of ukraine the unhcr
says more than 1.2 million have left
ukraine in the last eight days most have
crossed into neighboring poland and
hungary thousands are being welcomed
into germany europe is granting them
special protections circumventing asylum
procedures and giving them access to
health care and housing but the flood of
people leaving their homes is happening
so fast it's creating huge challenges
jamie morocco reports
grabbing her first meal after crossing
the polish ukrainian border katarina
jerichova looks almost relieved i took
money and my documents
and
and it's all maybe one
t-shirt the 25 year old is safe and has
plans to go to a small city outside of
warsaw but for thousands of others who
don't have set plans there are hurdles
they will face if you have a large
number of people
migrating in a short period of time
they're at risk of
infectious disease right now covet is a
big one
as the war began coveted cases in
ukraine were up 550 percent according to
a un report vaccination rates are fairly
low at just 36 percent covet is not
their main priority right now obviously
they're a lot survival and taking care
of their kids and making sure that they
get a next meal as they flee is going to
be their main problem paul spiegel is
the director of the center for
humanitarian health at johns hopkins on
wednesday the canadian will be flying to
poland to support the world health
organization's refugee emergency
response you do everything from tracking
the actual
outbreak of surveillance to then
treatment and it's labor intensive and
that will be
much more challenging in ukraine proper
than outside
forced into tight quarters basements and
bomb shelters covid tuberculosis measles
chickenpox and even polio could threaten
lives experts say shelling has damaged
water systems and communicable diseases
are now also becoming a concern
for those who do get sick hospitals are
already overwhelmed with traumas and
access to essential medicine has
dwindled although a humanitarian
corridor has opened the need is
outpacing supply
for this 19 year old who escaped the
shock of leaving home is setting in
nothing can be important is in my family
the responsibilities host countries now
have
is keeping them healthy and safe jamie
morocco global news toronto
compelled to act a canadian's courage
and kindness
[Music]
what's unfolding in ukraine is driving
thousands of people to ask what they can
do to help for one calgary father who is
visiting family in a country near
ukraine the answer was simple jamie dahl
has his story
it is impossible to measure heartache
but we can all feel it
and in witnessing moments like these a
father forced to say goodbye to his
little girl and wife not knowing if
they'll ever see or hold each other
again
it's hard to detach from the pain being
felt in ukraine i'm emotional now just
saying thinking about that but i know
what that would feel like and
no parent should have to go through that
but dan koska needed to do more than
just bear witness he's a father of two
from calgary he and his family were
neighboring slovakia visiting loved ones
when war broke out there was no question
in my mind i was so determined to
to get to the border and help some
people loaded up with supplies and food
he drove 500 kilometers from the
slovakian capital to the small stretch
of ukrainian border where the u.n
reports more than 90 000 people have
crossed already seeking safety they were
woken up at six a.m on the morning of
the invasion by a bombing of the airport
near their town two days after he got to
the border kotsko was back on the
highway with these two women and their
children who had survived a harrowing
escape from ukraine leaving their
husbands behind they're exhausted
relieved uh several times they they
referred to me they said you're our hero
and
it was very touching to hear that and i
just smiled and accepted it and at the
same time i thought i'm not doing
anything very brave i'm doing something
compassionate but not brave the brave
people are the people they left behind
the men
who are fighting
this war we caught up with the women now
safe in slovakia's capital some slovak
people give us a flat
free free no without any payment we are
brave
and all our citizens are very patriotic
we hope and we believe
that ukraine will win and i think it
will be not
been just
for ukraine it will be been from the for
all well koska is heading back to the
border this weekend with more supplies
and space in his car you need good
people to help other good people
because we're so ugly
war is indeed ugly
thankfully there are many working so
hard to show compassion
amidst the turmoil
jamie dahl global news calgary
and we leave you tonight with another
war going on the fight to control
information in russia the kremlin
silences political opponents and
controls the state media today it went a
step further making it a criminal act to
stray from the kremlin narrative about
this war the duma the russian parliament
unanimously approved a draft law making
it a criminal offense to call what's
happening in ukraine a war or an
invasion anyone who says otherwise and
is convicted faces up to 15 years in
jail in response the bbc's interim
director tweeted this it's with a heavy
heart that we have to suspend bbc news
operations in russia until we assess the
impact of new laws which outlaw
independent journalism multiple news
organizations have followed suit and in
russia multiple sites are blocked
including bbc voice of america deutsche
bella facebook instagram and twitter for
what the kremlin calls discrimination
against russian media
russia's tv reign held its final
broadcast last night
no to war were the final words staff
walked off the set leaving this
[Music]
the russian ballet swan lake
it's what aired on russian state tv in
august of 1991 after the failed coup
attempt that marked the beginning of the
end of the soviet union
thanks for watching
[Music]
you